[Music]
the series finale of Game of Thrones is
finally here it may not be what many
were expecting or even hoping for but a
trail of clues was laid out over the
seasons which pointed to how it would
all end new PK movie lovers I'm John and
in this video I'm delving into all the
foreshadowing and hidden symbolism that
predicted Daenerys Targaryen ultimate
destiny and to mark the ending of this
epic saga I'm kicking off a new Game of
Thrones giveaway subscribe hit the bell
and leave a comment about the show for a
chance to win of course spoilers ahead
so take care if you're not up to date
Game of Thrones fan Z used to shocking
moments but some of the most
controversial in the series so far have
been the final two episodes of the
series when Danny burned King's Landing
to the ground massacring her enemies and
common folk alike followed by her lover
Jon Snow stabbing and killing her in the
throne room it was a brutal end for the
mother of dragons who'd always believed
she was destined to rule on the Iron
Throne so my little princess what is it
you want my birthright Seven Kingdoms of
Westeros she finally touched the throne
she desired for so long and when she
asked Jon to break the wheel and build a
new world together they passionately
kissed but Jon stabbed his queen in the
chest
Danny had actually foreseen her destiny
at the end of the second season when she
had a revelation in the house of the
undying in that vision Danny walked
through the destroyed throne room in
King's Landing and after reaching out to
touch the Iron Throne she pulled her
hand away a sign of what was to come in
the finale she does touch the throne
making us think that perhaps reality
will be different to the vision but just
as Danny feels like she's finally
achieved what she came for Jon Snow
ominously appears behind her remember
that in her vision snow was falling and
it's Jon Snow who's here to prevent her
from ruling over the Seven Kingdoms the
snow in the vision also resembles the
flakes of ash that fell on King's
Landing after Danny burned the city down
a reminder that when Danny said I am NOT
here to be queen of the ashes Jon Snow
made sure that he would literally stop
her from doing that Danny's death was
also foretold in her vision when she
passed from the throne room through a
door into another world signifying her
transition from this world to the
afterlife
in the
she walks out beyond the wall something
which also came true in season seven and
then she enters Drogo's tent to reunite
with him and Rago her stillborn child
she's mr. Tuvok she's Swedish I should I
think Danny's mention of dark magic in
her vision is interesting because it's
John who takes Danny's life and it was
Melisandre in her magic which brought
Jon Snow back to life after he died in
the tent with Drogo Dany also wonders if
she's in a dream which is worth noting
because the mother of dragons has a
history of making her dreams into a
reality how many centuries that have
been since dragons roamed the skies but
I dreamt and if I carried those eggs
into a great fire they would hatch I'm
no ordinary woman my dreams come true
so could Danny's tragic end in the
finale mean her vision of being reunited
with her son and stars in the night
lands has finally come true well you
could interpret it that way but not if
you listen to Jon Snow so is there life
after death
not that I've seen the way Dany dies at
John's hand also relates back to ancient
prophecies about the prince that was
promised that were first introduced to
the TV show by Melisandre the prophecy
which was also known as azor Ahai in the
books was misinterpreted a few times by
the red woman who first assumed the
prince that was promised with Stannis in
the legend of azor Ahai the sword that
could defeat the darkness could only be
forged when the hero drove it into the
chest of his beloved Nissa Nissa after
Stannis was defeated in the TV series
Melisandre switched to believing Jon
Snow as a prince that was promised but
the show had also presented Daenerys as
a likely candidate when a different red
priestess Kimbra spoke to tyrion and
varys
Daenerys Stormborn is the one who was
promised from the fire she was reborn to
remake the world and when Melisandre met
with Dany the Dragon Queen asked her and
you believe this prophecy refers to me
prophecies are dangerous things I
believe you have a role to play as does
another the king in the north
Jon Snow as Melisandre learned from her
past miscalculations prophecies aren't
necessarily what we assumed them to be
and we shouldn't take them too literally
and as it turned out in the end there
were two stages to the prophecy many
thought the threat of an eternal win
been defeated when iuck Illinois King in
the final battle of the great war at
Winterfell
but it was telling that in the final
episode snow began to fall on King's
Landing after Danny had taken the city
signaling that the threat to humanity
had not yet been fully defeated for the
prophecy to finally be fulfilled then
Jon Snow had to kill Daenerys the story
we've been watching is a Song of Ice and
Fire and by the end both Ice and Fire
have been defeated and it's only the
combination of Ice and Fire in John snow
with his dual stark and Targaryen
heritage that finally brings a prophecy
to its conclusion and there's proof that
winter is finally on its way to being
over when Jon Snow and the wildlings
opened the gate at Castle black and
marched north beyond the wall walking
past a little green chute emerging from
the snow in fact that's also likely a
nod to the title of George RR Martin's
7th an apparent final book a dream of
spring as rushed and problematic as this
season has certainly been the idea that
Danny's death was the way to bring peace
to Westeros was foreshadowed back in the
first season in Danny's encounter with
Murray mazdoor when Drogo was dying from
an infected wound Daenerys
turned for help to the lazarum priestess
who then performed a blood magic ritual
on the dying car during the ceremony the
pregnant Daenerys also went into labor
and Mirri Maz Duur helped deliver her
baby after Danny recovered from the
birth she discovered that her son Rago
was stillborn
and that Drogo had been cursed to never
recover Dany protested to the priestess
about what she'd done but Mary's
response was actually did it to stop
Khal Drogo's son from ever being born
and the destruction that he would have
brought on her people and the world this
is not God's work my child was innocent
innocent he would have been the stallion
who mounts the world now he will burn no
cities now his khalasar will trample no
nations into dust Jon Snow's murder of
Daenerys mirrors what mirror master did
to danny's son each one killed an
important figure to save the rest of the
world from the death and destruction
they thought they would bring when Danny
objected to Mary's actions the priestess
scoffed at the notion I saved you saved
me three of those riders had already
raped me before you saved me girl in the
streets I saw piles of heads the head of
a young boy that I cured
favorite just three moons past so tell
me again exactly what it was that you
saved even if we feel that Mary was
cruel to Daenerys who herself was not
directly responsible for what the
Dothraki did to Marie's village Danny's
sense of righteousness about her destiny
has always been a blind spot and when
she burns down King's Landing
Danny clearly doesn't see the irony of
her words last season that she wouldn't
be queen of the ashes and after the
slaughter her army and Dragon have
brought on the city she gives a chilling
speech to her troops proclaiming them to
be liberators Delamere haces tat in bad
bad dog via via bear leader ending so
marie Maz Duur did have a point when she
asked Danny what it was that she thought
she was saving and if Danny's visions
from the house of the undying azor Ahai
prophecies and Mearing mazdoor curses
weren't enough to warn us about what the
mother of dragons eventual fate would be
then there was also Jon Snow's previous
girlfriend yes there was yet another big
hint - Danny's eventual death in the
first episode of season 8 when after
arriving in Winterfell she and Jon went
on a dragon ride together in a moment
that called back to Jon Snow's previous
doomed lover Ygritte we could stay a
thousand years no one would find us
let's not go back it seems that loving
Jon Snow will ultimately end up killing
you Ygritte died when she hesitated to
kill Jon Snow during the wildling attack
on Castle black
Jon had abandoned Ygritte when he was
forced to choose between his duty to the
Nights Watch and loyalty to her
antarians words to Jon in the finale are
not that again he'll sacrifice his love
for Dany in favor of what is best for
the realm of is the death of duty
sometimes Duty is the death of love now
what was your verdict on how Game of
Thrones ended and how do you feel about
Danny's final fate leave your thoughts
below and subscribe to enter my Thrones
giveaway there's more Game of Thrones
videos on the way so tapleft for the
next one or tap write for another video
you're sure to LIKE and if you enjoyed
this a thumbs up in a shirt hugely
appreciated that
for watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers